in today's information driven world data
analytics is used in every sector be it
in companies where meaningful insights
are drawn pertaining to the company
growth or beat and fighting the ongoing
covit 19 pandemic data finds its usage
everywhere companies worldwide are
looking for skilled professionals who
can manage and handle critical business
data as a result people looking to grow
their career in analytics have a lot of
career options
so if you are one of those who likes to
or wants to play with data then nothing
can beat a career in the field of data
analytics
get prepared to start your data
analytics career with us
simply learn skill up course provides
the best introduction to the ever
expanding field of data analytics
the best part about it is that you can
take up this course for free
yes you can begin your data analytics
learning journey with us free of cost
and get a course completion certificate
for the same let us take you through the
details of our free data analytics
introduction course simply learn skill
up course on introduction to data
analytics course especially designed for
beginners who want to learn data
analytics from scratch the topics
covered in this course are types of data
analytics data visualization for
decision making
frequency distribution plots swarm plots
data science methodologies analytics
adoption frameworks and trends in data
analytics to name a few
this free skill up course gives you a
complete overview of data analytics and
how it is used
the course duration is three hours and
all the modules are self-paced video
lessons with 90 days of access to the
entire course this allows you to learn
at your own pace at your convenience
after completing this course you are
awarded a course completion certificate
for the same
this certificate can be shared within
your professional circle isn't that
great
so now you might be wondering if you're
eligible to take up this data analytics
course
well yes you are eligible since there
are no predefined eligibility criteria
to enroll in this course
however an understanding of mathematics
fundamentals is highly beneficial this
foundational data analytics course is
also ideal for anyone who is aspiring to
become a data analyst or analytics
manager the average annual salary range
of a data analyst is 3 lakhs 2 000
rupees to 10 lakhs 23 000 rupees
meanwhile an analytics manager's average
annual salary range is 9 lakhs 45 000
rupees to 34 lakhs 6 000 rupees so what
are you waiting for head straight to our
scala page and enrich your data
analytics knowledge by enrolling in our
free introduction to data analytics
course today consider this certification
as your first stepping stone towards
growing your data analytics career pack
this golden opportunity and get
certified with simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here